As we mentioned so far we've only done
flow estimations and pairs of images.
Now one way of thinking
about doing tracking is if
you had more than two images you could
do some form of optical flow or, or
some sort motion between one image and
the next and then you could just do it
between the second image and the third,
and the third image and the fourth.
Basically you would just sort of
follow the arrows, connect the dots.
So there are a couple of
challenges to just doing that.
One as we saw, it's hard to
compute optical flow everywhere.
You have to have just kind of
the right types of behavior for
the gradient, in terms of being
able to track these features.
Second, there might be
large displacement so
between one frame and the next
something may have moved a lot and so
there's a lot of search
that has to be done.
And so one way of doing that is you
might want to take the dynamics
into account.
How is this thing moving?
Make a prediction.
And in fact that's what we're going to
spend a lot of time talking about
over the next couple of lessons.
The other problem with sort of
connecting the dots is things
will drift.
That is, you know, I make a little
mistake, and then a little more mistake,
a little, and eventually,
I'm no longer tracking the thing that I
had started wanting to keep track of.
And then finally,
another problem is what are called
occlusions or disocclusions, right?
Occlusion is when
something gets occluded.
Disocclusion, maybe
unocclusion's a better word,
basically it appears from something.
So something appears, was it
something that had I lost before or
is it something new and
how do I do that kind of tracking?